okay so three thoughts occur to me i'm
gonna say them and then just so that i
don't forget them and then we can tackle
them one by one
okay so number one you mentioned everett
and i believe everett was a proponent of
many worlds i'm in i'm not sure about
that so okay you nodding your head so if
that's the case well if he
in many ways realized this relative
notion of quantum mechanics the
relational notion so why did he move to
many worlds so that's one i'm going to
say the others so don't forget them
number two
when we're speaking even right now just
with the english language it seems
incredibly
misleading because as soon as i say i
look right there i use the word i and
you also mentioned as many philosophers
come to similar conclusions well what is
this i what is behind so soon as you
start to analyze any word as soon as i
say cup well what is the cup
okay you we realize that
every everyday language is beguiling so
you can't actually describe reality no
i'm wondering
is there something similar with math
do you believe that math is somehow
exempt from this that math is actually
can't math actually can describe reality
so that's my number two don't worry i've
got all these in my head and the number
three was i didn't hear
an answer to whether or not the laws
themselves like the rules of the game
are part of the game or in other words
if when one thinks of reality as a whole
is one also supposed to think of
the laws that reality operate by as
being a part of reality so let's get to
number one why did everett come to
alternate conclusions yes um so the the
first thing you asked is uh um
um
you said everett is is considered uh
sort of the beginning of a many world
interpretation that's correct
no that's correct and uh in fact uh many
people who like the many world
interpretation called all calls this
expedition also the everett interpreter
right i think that's where i got this
called himself everything
um
everett wrote a
a a fantastic paper plus other
other things in which there are a number
of ideas
um we also have the um
the thesis that everett wrote when he
left physics
um
so
one question
it might be what he himself actually
thought about quantum mechanics but
that's not a very interesting question i
mean
what is interesting is not what actually
people thought at some time what is
interesting what can we do with the with
their ideas and their text
and everett has introduced this notion
of
relational states
which i think it's it is spectacularly
good
and one way
of developing that idea is relational
quantum mechanics namely thinking that
properties are all relational
another way of developing that idea
is the many world interpretation so if
you want from evidence you you can
branch off to two possible
uh directions of thinking about quantum
theory
the mineral interpretation
it goes the opposite direction than
relational quantum mechanics even if it
has this common idea that properties are
relatively they
many more people will say to to system
into branches
um the the main world idea is is is
contrary is to take
the wave functional universe seriously
and think that this is all there is this
wave function of the universe this
overall uh super quantum state in which
we are sitting
and uh um
and all the rest has to be sort of
extracted from
derived from from
from this wave function of the universe
this wave function of everything and
that's a real stuff that's sort of the
main world interpretation
um it's very interesting
i don't like it very much i think as
i said at the beginning each
interpretation is a cost and i don't
think it's a cost
that is bringing us ahead
because uh you know if you think
uh if you if you take it seriously
[Music]
the universe is sort of constantly
splitting in multiple
branches of this big wave function
where you and i are copied millions and
millions of times
so you would think that there is the
other the other the other copies of
non-realized
uh yeah
you might think that way but it's
nothing wrong but i don't think it's
useful